the Joe Rogan experience yeah did you
hear that uh re spiked Burt's drink with
Molly what they did a podcast together
and re dumped Molly into Burt's drink
wait is that why Bert's wife isn't
talking RN exactly wait that's what wait
one podcast in his house in Bert's house
what at what family are you so crazy I
don't trust him for a second I'm so
scared of Ari Shaffir he's [ __ ] crazy
I've seen him just like act asked about
my life and be like interested now like
open up to him and then he'll like use
it against me later on I'm like this guy
yeah he'll just like store up things use
it against not using mom to be funny
hmm I think he's evil oh no he fears
secretly evil secretly evil yeah I think
you'll yeah I do I think he's a good I
like him but I don't trust him because I
because he spiked Burke he gave his
friend Molly that's not okay it's not
okay but wait that's hilarious though
that's what I do like about dude they
were out both on Molly because I already
took it himself okay and the podcasts
going on it already starts dance and
he's like sort of dancing and move in
and births like what do you want Molly
he goes are you Birds like what and then
all of a sudden and then he realizes
like what's going on he realizes and the
arse are gonna put some in your drinks
like oh he's home with his family
okay I kind of want Ari to spike my
drink and I want them to be you don't
you to do Molly sorry Ari no do it not
it again don't you trouble I'm giving
you consent to do it to me in a sneaky
podcast oh I think that'd be so fun
I wish Joe that's my thing I need an
excuse to be bad like that's why I like
bondage it's like oh no like I can't do
this I'm forced to do this dirty thing I
really want to do this but you're making
a doing that's why it's a Dancing with
the Stars I'm like you made me wear this
swimsuit on TV I can't not be a [ __ ]
what's the shoulder thing it's just like
helpless [ __ ] like I need the excuse to
be bad to be what I really want to be
which is hi [ __ ] yeah um and mean like
the roast roast it's an excuse to be
mean it's excused to be evil I had to do
these drugs too
what am I gonna go to a roast and
compliment everyone I can't do that
so there so there's always there's
always I had to I get it I get it
well you just gave Ari the excuse and
believe me he's gonna capitalize on it
I really do want to do Molly I feel like
I'll just do it with him no not with him
I would do someone recommended him to be
my shaman on a trip and I was like what
the [ __ ] I don't trust him to be my
shaman who the trust
rasca he's gonna ask oh well whatever so
maybe mushrooms was like so I was like
trust him for that fill me up that mouth
okay look you could trust ari Ari was
just mad at Burton it's not logical it's
not tenable I don't I don't agree with
them he's mad at Bert that the whole
reason why we do sober October was we
were trying to get Bert sober and Bert
was you know we were worried about his
health like yeah Bert's ridiculously
overweight and he's also on high blood
pressure medication but yet he still
drinks every [ __ ] night really this
is crazy man like you get you got to
stop doing this
[Applause]